news now investigators not only broke
the news about the Escape hours before
officials said anything about it they
also broke the escapees capture last
night eight news now investigator David
charns asking the governor today about
the timeline we had a prisoner who's on
the loose a convicted murderer you are
the governor of the state of Nevada and
you were not told for four days and
there are members of the prison
commission you sit on who said they
found out when we published our article
before the Department of Corrections
even issued a statement I was very upset
very disappointed that that's what
happened I don't know now they said it
could have been as early as Friday we
don't know in fact when it happened well
it seemed like they lied to you because
you said something different and then
they came out about 15 minutes later and
said it was actually Friday yeah it
seems like that I didn't get the whole
story all of that is an investigation in
terms of not just what happened in terms
of how it was communicated to me and to
law enforcement into the general public
we will get to the bottom of what
happened and appropriate action will be
taken against anybody that was involved
in it believe me do you think your own
department is working against you and
lying it's not your department but over
the department you technically oversee I
don't think you're working against me I
think that they were uh neglect and
negligent in some areas here
and